الوزارات الثلاثه التي تحدثنا عنها
الخارجيه والدفاع والداخليه من المتوقعه
ان تلعب دورا كبيرا في الملف السوري الى
جانب جهاز الاستخبارات وزير الخارجيه
الجديد هكان فيدان بصفته رئيسا
للاستخبارات سابقا كان له دور في قياده
عمليه المحادثات الاستخباريه مع الحكومه
السوريه كما نذكر والتي وصلت لاحقا الى
مستويات ارفع على صعيد الوزراء الدفاع
والخارجيه برعايه روسيه من المتوقع ان
يعمل فيدان بالتنسيق مع وزاره الدفاع
وجهاز الاستخبارات على معالجه البعدين
الامني والعسكري في سوريا مع استبعاد
تركيا الانسحاب من الشمال السوري والعمل
على محاربه قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه هذا عن
الجانب الدبلوماسي ممثلا بوزاره الخارجيه
اما في المجال الامني فيبرز دور يشار
جولار في حقيبه الدفاع الان فهو رئيس
الاركان السابق كما ذكرنا والمقرب من سلفه
خلص اكار لكن بقاء جولر فتره طويله في ظل
اداره اثار القويه لن يعني بحسب محللين ان
يكون له دور ثانوي في معالجه الملف السوري
مع توقعات بان يعمل جولار في هذا الملف
بالتنسيق بشكل مباشر مع اردوغان
والان الى ملف اللاجئين السوريين ودور
وزاره الداخليه بطبيعه الحال حيث ستكون
لدى الوزير علير لكايا صلاحيه واسعه فيما
يتعلق بملف السوريين الذين يقيمون في
تركيا تحت بند الحمايه المؤقته ويبدو ان
الوزير لكايا جمع خبره تراكميه خاصه في ظل
قربه من سلفه سليمان
وبعد حضوره المباشر لعمليه تنظيم وجود
السوريين في اسطنبول التي كان واليا سابقا
عليها وبعد اطلاعه على الدق حيث ياتي هذا
الملف
عن خمس سنوات مقبله من حكم اردوغان ربما
لا تحمل ما يشيء بحل كامل للملف السوري
بجانبيه الخارجي والداخلي بالنسبه لانقره
الا انها قد تشهد حلحله جزئيه قائمه على
مساري التطبيع مع دمشق والعمل في ان واحد
على محاوله تخفيف الوجود السوري داخل
تركيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات